je me suis retrouvé embarqué impliqué
ils sont vachement bon et petit à petit
j'ai fait tomber le masque du
journalisme
à mon tour j'ai eu envie de les
encourager
tout simplement eu envie qu'il s'en
sorte
[Musique]
tout petit je rêvais d'aider les autres
sauver secourir protéger
finalement je suis journaliste
alors j'ai décidé d'aller à la rencontre
de ces hommes et de ses femmes
ordinaires qui exercent des métiers hors
du commun aujourd'hui je suis à Narbonne
dans un centre éducatif fermé pour les
mineurs délinquants c'est la dernière
chance avant la prison en prison il
suffit d'un jour pour savoir
jour et nuit 24 adultes encadrent 12
garçons la plupart
multirécidiviste toujours sur un film si
ça ne se passe pas bien ici ce sera la
prison fils de [__] à 17 ans en moyenne
ils ont déjà un petit pedigree ceux qui
vous ont amenés ici c'est vos actes de
délinquance vol braquage violence
agression sexuelle trafic de drogue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la nuit enveloppe encore le centre c'est
l'heure du réveil la nuit comment prison
les portes sont fermées
les éducateurs ont toujours le trousseau
de clés à la main
tu as bien dormi
[Musique]
12 chambres pour 12 ados délinquants et
pas des enfants de chœur
tu te réveilles mais le thon est plutôt
bienveillant c'est bon à tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui c'est Max 36 ans éducateur
spécialisé qui réveille les troupes
c'est pas évident de les motiver et avec
Max pour faire le tour des chambres deux
autres éducateurs
ils veulent pas sortir du lit il faut y
passer plusieurs fois il y a le réveil
qui est un peu compliqué et le coucher
le coucher c'est les angoisses nocturnes
aussi ça c'est des moments particuliers
comme ça mais c'est ce qui crée des
liens avec l'éduc aussi c'est des
moments clés de la journée ça
ici que des garçons pas de fille moyenne
d'âge 17 ans en général plusieurs
affaires correctionnelles sur le dos
pour lesquelles ils n'ont pas encore été
jugés
et justement aujourd'hui l'un d'entre
eux est convoqué au tribunal max
s'inquiète de ne pas le voir encore
debout
depuis 7h mais c'est le jeune qui a un
jugement donc je pense qu'il est en
train de
mettre un peu stressé quoi Farid a mal
dormi max le sang l'ado est préoccupé
par sa convocation devant le juge
pour des faits de violence répétés avant
le 16 pendant le sève en dehors du CF
avec sa famille à l'extérieur donc ça
fait plusieurs fois qu'il a des ventes
d'incidents et là il va passer devant le
juge il risque d'être révoqué sans
contrôle judiciaire
dans ce cas là il risque de la prise en
ferme
l'enjeu est important si l'adolescent ne
respecte pas le règlement intérieur du
centre le juge pour enfants peut à tout
moment l'envoyer en prison
vu de l'extérieur le Sèvre ressemble à
un petit collège planté au milieu d'une
zone industrielle sauf qu'ici il y a une
caméra et un grand portail métallique
le mecs qui font la clope
sous le préau
des centres comme celui-ci il en existe
45 en France pour garçon pour fille
parfois mixte
la protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
a choisi de m'envoyer à Narbonne
j'imagine donc que la structure
fonctionne bien je suis accueilli par le
directeur Christophe Warnault l'homme
qui fait tourner la structure depuis 5
ans
c'est un convaincu du système au moment
où les sèves sont très controversés
françois Hollande veut en doubler le
nombre mais ces détracteurs dénoncent
leur coûts prohibitifs quel est le coût
du Narbonne on est sur une moyenne de
520 euros depuis 5 ans d'accord
520 euros par jour et par jeune 5 fois
le prix d'une journée en prison
maintenant c'est on peut réfléchir sur
est-ce que c'est cher si on s'occupe de
notre jeunesse pour le futur ce ne sont
pas des délinquants pour moi ici sont
des jeunes qui ont commis plusieurs
actes de délinquance assez clair est-ce
qu'ils vont s'y maintenir ou non c'est
encore une autre vision donc on sert à
ça justement
chaque année en France plus de 1000
gamins sont placés dans des centres
éducatifs fermés ils ont trafiqué volé
braquer et même parfois violer ils sont
placés ici pour une durée de six mois
renouvelable une fois
durant mon séjour plusieurs visages vont
vite me devenir familier
Myriam la logistique à l'intendance au
centre c'est elle là
33 ans éducateur ici depuis 5 ans
[Musique]
aujourd'hui l'audience de Farid devant
le juge va concentrer toutes les
attentions
ce gamin le voici en pantalon blanc et
capuche noire c'est la seule image que
vous verrez car il a toujours fui notre
caméra
9h c'est l'heure du briefing des
éducateurs avec les ados c'est là que
sont annoncés les activités du jour et
ça commence par un petit recadrage
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
nous irons à ton audience c'est moi de
révocation éventuelle de Total aux
parties du SMO
non
un sport avec Régis
aller au boulot tout le monde la pause à
10 30
c'est un peu ce sentiment de voir
espèce de fauve en fait
pas socialement quoi bon
pour encadrer ces 12 mineurs 24 adultes
des éducateurs mais aussi un
psychanalyste et un enseignant
tous les jours de 9h à 17h les activités
s'enchaînent
moi je suis de corvée de patate avec
maniaque le cuistot il en faut combien
un peu plus tard à l'étage je retrouve
Myriam en pleine mission de ménage je
regrette pas de d'être venu pour voir ça
au début ça avait pas l'allumer
l'aspirateur
donc il découvre l'aspirateur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mets-toi dépêche-toi
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on doit en déduire c'est un
doudou c'est un souvenir ça c'est à mon
neveu
[Musique]
les secrets mais ils ont l'impression
que ça sort pas ça sort pas quoi que
c'est entre nous mais c'est bien je ne
dis pas tout non plus parce que sinon ce
serait de travailler allez un coup de
serre pierre bien dessous bien là-haut
là
Myriam c'est être la confidente mais
c'est aussi l'oeil de Moscou rien ne lui
échappe
[Musique]
subitement l'attention est monté d'un
cran
Myriam alambude elle sort de la chambre
un éducateur prend le relais
[Musique]
un simple regard tu vois là j'ai touché
un truc voilà
très très fragile
et c'est pour ça je pense qu'on est vite
fatigué parce qu'on est toujours sur le
qui-vive pour faire attention à tout
ce qui se passe en face de nous à droite
à gauche on brosse avec des rétroviseurs
donc c'est ça je pense qu'il nous
fatigue cet attention de on a 100% du
mode et on sort
c'est comme ça dans ce genre de centre
ambiance décontractée genre colonie de
vacances et puis brutalement sans savoir
pourquoi la violence
Farid a déjà fugué du centre et comme il
dévoile les violences graves pendant son
placement il avait déjà écopé d'un
sursis avec mise à l'épreuve révocable à
tout moment
en clair il pourrait être envoyé en
prison ce soir pendant qu'il se prépare
les éducs s'interrogent ils sont divisés
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on dit c'est la dernière chose
à la prochaine infraction ça tombe c'est
chocolat
qui a eu les meneurs de mort envers le
directeur et les violences légères
envers Tristan écoute plus rien qu'on
prend plus rien il faut un moment qu'il
y a quelque chose qui tombe pour qu'il
est à repère je crois toi tu penses
qu'il faut d'injustice
prévue par le SME elle fasse fonction
finaliser un placement par
l'incarcération c'est un peu dommage
quoi il lui reste quoi un mot dans ses
18 ans ah oui mais en fait
le bilan de si oui est-ce que c'est
cohérent de courage
pour lui dire que si vous faites pour
lui dire que la limite existe
pas facile de situer la frontière entre
devoir éducatifs et sanction
le juge tranchera Farid part pour le
tribunal avec un peu d'appréhension
[Musique]
changement de décor dans une ferme à un
quart d'heure de là Lionel le psy du
centre fait du théâtre avec deux jeunes
l'improvisation est ici une thérapie
D
l'improvisation fait qu'on va chercher
des choses qui viennent spontanément
donc on puisse dans l'inconscient et
l'important c'est qu'il crée un
personnage le plus suffisamment bizarre
pour pouvoir dire des choses sur eux à
travers ce personnage parce que trop
direct ce serait trop brutal à mon tour
je décide de me lancer petite
improvisation perso pour les encourager
je l'ai découvert la première fois que
je suis allé en prison j'ai un pouvoir
extraordinaire je saute les murs de
prison ça fait quatre fois que je suis
condamné pour évasion récidiviste
c'est un truc qui pourrit la vie
[Applaudissements]
au centre il y a aussi la musique avec
Max
[Musique]
et le sport la musculation ou la boxe
des activités prises à chaque fois pour
leurs vertus éducatives
[Musique]
une fois par semaine les éducateurs et
les jeunes se réunissent pendant une
heure pour un temps de parole collectif
aujourd'hui c'est Max qui lance le débat
s'il y a beaucoup de gens c'est clair ça
c'est un délit commun après ce que tous
les jeunes moi je différencie quand même
un jeune qui va voler une pomme de terre
pour manger et un jeune en France des
fois qui vole nous quand on voit ce que
vous faites des fois avec l'argent quand
vous nous dites j'ai fait ça j'ai fait
ça c'est souvent une paire de Nike Air
parce qu'on voit les autres avec hyper
Norman
nous il faut dire ce qu'il y a on a
choisi le chemin plus facile on voulait
une paire de Nike on a choisi le moyen
le plus rapide de s'en acheter voilà on
s'est fait baiser
pourquoi lui il a et moi j'ai pas
il y a des gens qui galèrent pas pour
manger il y a des gens qui galèrent pour
manger c'est ça la différence mais les
gens les riches c'est pas le bonheur et
les pauvres le malheur le bonheur chacun
essaie de se fabriquer autour de soi et
c'est pas forcément lié à l'argent alors
après moi je n'entends que il faut un
minimum pour manger pour vivre ça oui et
que on peut nourrir de la haine parce
qu'on n'a pas le minimum mais quand on a
le minimum minimum si tu passes ta vie
être jaloux de celui qui est au-dessus
jusqu'à ce que tu sois Liliane
Bettencourt tu seras malheureux quoi
le but le but c'est c'est je sais pas
c'est tombé amoureux peut-être avoir des
enfants
un job un job où on voit pas tous les
matins avec la corde au cou parce qu'on
n'aime pas son job moi je suis content
je suis arrivé ce matin chez vous moi
j'ai passé une super journée je pense
que j'ai un métier formidable la
richesse peut être ailleurs
[Musique]
ces jeunes sont objectivement
intelligents ils ont des choses à dire
j'ai envie d'aller plus loin pour mieux
les comprendre
au bureau des éducateurs guillaume est
fait sale font passer un entretien de
fin de placement à JB
dans deux jours JB sera majeur il devra
quitter le centre Guillaume se souvient
d'une anecdote JB lui envoyer des textos
problèmes ici le téléphone portable est
interdit
o
[Musique]
en 7 mois de vie commune au centre
Guillaume a tissé une vraie complicité
avec JB il tente de l'aider jusqu'au
bout pour son bilan
milieu
si ça t'a apporté quelque chose tu vois
toutes ces petits éléments mais
aujourd'hui JB n'a aucune envie de faire
des efforts
et d'essayer de faire quelque chose de
constructif mais n'importe quoi
est-ce que est-ce que
tu fais pas en chambre il y a que ça
t'augué tu as jamais fugué
voilà
pendant 5 mois
il a pas envie d'admettre devant nous
que que
son passage ici lui a peut-être servi
aussi lien avec la famille
avec ta famille
avec toute ta famille
non avec mon père
est-ce que tu as été en lien avec tu me
disais il est pas ta famille ton père
situation familiale très compliquée
où ils n'ont pas forcément
ce qu'ils aimeraient avoir et où ils ont
pas forcément l'amour de leur de leurs
parents ou là où l'attention de parents
voilà qui peuvent peut-être à des
moments trouver aussi
le centre permet aux ados de rompre avec
leur milieu de les éloigner de leur
quotidien mais on essaye de garder le
lien avec les familles au début elles
peuvent venir au centre tous les 15
jours puis au bout de deux mois les
jeunes peuvent rentrer chez eux le
week-end sous réserve de l'accord de
juge
rien
on va manger
l'ambiance est bonne on pourrait presque
croire à un repas de famille tout le
monde mange au réfectoire et heure fixe
c'est une astreinte mais c'est pas le
bail non plus
[Musique]
certains s'aventurent même à essayer le
micro de notre percheman il faut que tu
la tienne au-dessus évidemment parce que
il faut pas qu'on la voit dans le
probable faut pas qu'on la voit dans le
champ après le repas Sofiane exhib un
pantalon troué il espère que Myriam va
le lui recoudre
elle préfère lui mettre le fil et
l'aiguille dans les mains
regardez les enfants les choses rares
doivent se regarder
regardez là ceux qui sont présents
regardez vous le verrez pas souvent
et voilà comment sous le regard médusé
de manière
réussite à mettre un petit caïd à la
couture
quand soudain à l'étage
la mauvaise nouvelle tombe
Farid l'ado convoqué chez le juge ce
matin vient d'être incarcéré
pour faire un point pas forcément pour
expliquer son cas mais pour si vous avez
des questions
si vous avez des questions si vous avez
des remarques si vous avez une
appréhension
tu voulais que toi
Christophe Warnault le directeur décide
de réunir tout le monde pour une
remontée de bretelles générales et un
petit rappel à la loi la juge a décidé
de l'incarcéré un mois et demi
pour non respect de sursis
les raisons vous êtes dans un placement
judiciaire c'est votre Réal qualité
c'est pas de la faute des équipes et du
cassis c'est pas de la juge c'est pas de
la faute d'un éducateur ceux qui vous
ont amené ici c'est vos actes de
délinquance c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
surtout pour les gars parce que c'est
lui qui est vous aussi vous le prenez
vous le prenez mal mais sachez que pour
nous aussi c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
les gens qu'on est content les gars
mais peut-être mais en attendant c'est
ce que tu risques mais d'attendre en
prison ça t'arrange pas mais là tu as ma
chance de pouvoir avancer et travailler
c'est tout penser aux victimes
dans la rue qui ont été
volé taper violenter vous savez de quoi
je parle je mettrai pas sur la table les
affaires de chacun ici mais un moment
donné la
justice
la prison beaucoup ils sont déjà allés
des allers-retours entre deux placements
comme Georges 17 ans qui l'a plutôt mal
vécu
ça apporte rien
en prison il suffit d'un jour pour
savoir que ce qu'on a fait c'était pas
bien frais
c'est pas pareil il nous écoute
c'est pour ça c'est il t'ouvre la
cellule pour aller en cours il te la
refaire une fois que dans la chambre il
y a pas de bonjour il y a pas de est-ce
que tu vas bien il y a pas de malade
aujourd'hui tu veux rendez-vous chez le
médecin
d'ici des éducateurs tu en as croisé
tout depuis que j'ai 9 ans
on continue je suis jamais retourner
chez moi toutes sortes
d'éducateurs que ce soit niveau justice
niveau Aide à l'enfance
structure d'accueil structure d'urgence
tout aidé ou pas
jusqu'à maintenant
maintenant je me rends compte mais après
quand on est plus jeune c'est pas pareil
c'est ils savent très bien que on va
faire maximum à un an et demi deux ans
puis après nous verrons plus quoi qui
sont pas vraiment l'envie comme ici ici
je pars d'ici dans deux mois j'aurai 18
ans je sais que je pourrais pas faire
marche arrière j'aurais plus personne
derrière moi pour me dire ce que tu fais
ça serait bien que tu fasses ça essaie
ça
parce que c'est des personnes à qui on
sait qu'on peut parler et leur faire
confiance
ils sont sympas ces mecs
ils sont pas cons en plus
ces jeunes ont eu des parcours
difficiles mais au fond ce sont encore
des enfants
alors ici ils peuvent se poser réfléchir
à leurs actes reprendre confiance et
avec l'aide de leurs éducateurs tenter
de saisir cette dernière perche
[Musique]
le bonnet
aujourd'hui c'est journée ski direction
les Pyrénées deux heures de route pour
une journée détente max embarque quatre
jeunes dont JB qui quittera le centre de
main
la neige est au rendez-vous
[Musique]
allez c'est bien les gens normalement
de mettre les
vivre ce rêve de gosserait à la belle
étoile je veux pas regretter mon passé
en irakensant mais grandir voir mon
avenir avec des yeux d'enfants on a
qu'une seule chance avant de mettre les
voix je dois vivre ce rêve de gosse fait
à la belle et toi je pars regretter mon
passé en Iro pensant mais grandir voir
mon avenir avec mes yeux d'enfants je
sens chez Max l'envie de transmettre il
s'identifie à leurs problèmes lui aussi
a eu une adolescence difficile
[Musique]
j'étais bagarreur donc voilà ça aurait
pu mal tourner heureusement j'avais un
père qui s'occupait beaucoup de moi qui
était très aimant
et malgré ça l'adolescence c'est dur
hein c'est un cap
alors eux c'est des adolescents sans
cadres donc voilà ils font des conneries
des grosses conneries il y a des
victimes il faut pas oublier bon mais
voilà si on peut rattraper quelques
jeunes c'est quand même bien
un petit côté ou alors fais comme ça non
mais là de toute façon je sais pas où il
faut aller mais c'est pas sur une sortie
comme ça qu'on crée des fugues quoi le
jeûne qui veut fuguer il fugue du centre
fermé de toute façon ça va
retour au centre ce centre éducatif
fermé et loin d'être une prison les
grillages sont à hauteur d'homme le
portail est facile à franchir et puis il
y a les activités à l'extérieur au fond
tout repose sur la responsabilité des
jeunes une fugue ou un délit et c'est la
prison ce qui est arrivé à la farine
toutes les affaires de Farid sont
restées ici Myriam les rassemble elles
seront envoyées en prison est à limite
des objets mes traces des moins de 8
mois passés au centre mais aussi
l'absence dur à encaisser pour Myriam
parce qu'ils sont mignons petits
mois parfois un an à partager le
meilleur et le pire forcément Myriam
finit par s'attacher
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
malgré leur connerie tout ça je pense
qu'il y a une carence affective et tout
ça ça me fait du mal
j'ai eu beaucoup d'amour que j'étais
petite je me dis pourquoi eux
[Musique]
leurs histoires me touche tu vas dire un
policier fils de [__] à force de
partager des repas je suis si de
t'entendre des clopes et des émotions
fortes
je l'avoue
il monte
[Musique]
un parfum sur toi c'est quoi je me suis
retrouvé embarqué impliqué il sent
vachement bon et petit à petit
j'ai fait tomber le masque du
journaliste
à mon tour j'ai eu envie de les
encourager
qu'il s'en sorte
surprise en fin d'après-midi Ludovic est
un ancien pensionnaire sorti d'ici il y
a deux ans il vient récupérer des
papiers et il a plutôt le sourire très
bien très bien après
culture quelqu'un qui m'a pistonné dans
ce métier je suis rentré j'ai été deux
ans j'ai failli être deux ans
tous les matins à 6h30
c'est pour ça que j'ai besoin de mon
dossier
non j'ai arrêté de fumer
festif c'est festif maintenant c'est
tout pas de films
un peu parce que le jour où je peux je
suis sorti d'ici mon père il m'avait mis
dehors
ça vous savez pas donc après bon je fais
quelques conneries là après quand je
suis là aussi culture j'avais
l'appartement j'avais mon salaire donc
tu as pas de raison de faire j'avais pas
de raison de faire le con tu t'ennuyais
pas
donc le système c'est ça marche
la preuve c'est moi qui demande de
rester une six mois de plus j'étais bien
entouré ici chez moi j'étais pas entouré
j'en ai pas ma mère pas mon père enfin
bref que là j'étais maintenant tourner
donc je préférais continuellement projet
plutôt que de foire et dehors le
continuer le référence mais il faut
aussi la volonté quand quand je suis
sorti d'ici moi j'ai eu la volonté aussi
de réussir moi il faut y aller c'est sûr
qu'on dit qu'on a le chèque aussi ça
fait plaisir voilà c'est sûr qu'elle des
conneries tu prends 20 € par ci par là
mais quand tu touches chez mille cinq ou
quand tu fais la saison je touchais 2000
euros par mois des fois quand je vois je
faisais ses heures par jour aussi quand
même ça fait plaisir quoi
et après c'est l'argent propre quoi
c'est pas ça quoi
tu mérites dans mon plaisir
c'est
pour ça alors c'est pas du 100 % il y a
rien qui fonctionnait à 100% comme
Ludo on savait quand même que ça pouvait
accrocher assez un peu plus facilement
que d'autres c'est dans le temps moi je
pense qu'il faut attendre oui dans les
cinq années qui suivent quand même pour
voir véritablement où en sont ces jeunes
dans leur tête et en position de main de
place dans la société vous le savez ça
globalement
c'est difficile de suivre ceux qui
prennent le soin de rappeler oui ou de
donner des nouvelles mais après non
c'est pas évident
pour Ludovic le centre a été salutaire
même si à ce jour il n'existe aucune
statistique sérieuse sur les résultats
de ce genre de structure et sur le taux
de récidive des membres qui en sortent
il y en a un autre qui est sur le départ
C JB c'est sa dernière nuit et comme
c'est la coutume pour les jeunes qui
s'en vont Guillaume l'emmène au resto
avec Fred une autre éducatrice
demain JB aura 18 ans il sera obligé de
partir après le repas il semble cette
fois-ci plus disponible pour faire un
bilan
coucou neiger
s'occupe de vous en permanence
je l'ai plus encore travailler
il faut que tu t'occupes donc
mais nous donnons nos nouvelles
genre tu m'appelles c'est ça c'est pour
des nouvelles appeler c'est pourri c'est
déjà pas mal
[Musique]
pendant ce temps-là au centre un étrange
manège se met en place
quelque chose
l'abattoir jouxte de le centre les
éducateurs soupçonnent les jeunes vie
fumer du cannabis en cachette
[Musique]
quoi
c'est Sofiane qui est suspecté d'avoir
fumé du shit Max va fouiller sa chambre
et ce n'est pas la première fois
[Musique]
on va vous le dire d'arrêter de fumer
après tu vas être sanctionné qu'est-ce
que tu vas faire
on appelle la strainte
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que je viens de trouver mais
tu te rends compte que tu te détruire la
santé mais tu te rends compte
s'il vous plaît
mais qu'est-ce qui t'arrive
quoi là
tu peux pas nous en parler un petit peu
mais tu arrêtes pas
la gueule mais on est là par le nom mais
parle-nous et bien sûr pour toi bien sûr
qu'on passe à ton avenir on le sait très
bien
cette merde
tu ne seras plus jugé comme un mineur
tu comprends ça s'appelle la
récidivelégal j'espère que cette loi va
péter parce que tu vas manger tout un
sursis est-ce que tu as compris mais
c'est pour toi
on peut pas on peut pas te laisser
tranquille
ils ont l'impression que ça leur fait du
bien mais après il boit du noir il s'en
fatigués ils ont plus d'énergie puis moi
je crois que ça allait déprime encore
plus quoi ah oui ils ont l'impression
que ça les ramolli oui ça ne s'évader un
peu mais du coup ils ont pu la pêche et
tout ah c'est un jeune qui a vachement
la pêche qui est super fort en espoir il
a les capacité physique et normale et il
se détruit quoi mais bon
après c'est à tout âge ça c'est
l'échappatoire comme ça
mais lui il y a les deux
[Rires]
notes on envoie au juge après voilà
c'est la justice qui est franchement
est-ce que
voici la pièce à conviction quelques
micro boulettes de shit qui seront
envoyés au commissariat en même temps
qu'une note d'incidence a envoyé au juge
d'exceptionnel mais bon il est 22h30
JB et Guillaume rentrent du restaurant
[Musique]
dernière nuit pour JB
dernier au revoir de Guillaume
et si tu le vois tu passes le bonjour
Mon cœur
devant JB Guillaume garde le sourire
mais une fois seul avec Fred le ton se
fait plus grave ils sont inquiets pour
lui
-même
de l'autre côté et qui aura pas de
deuxième chance comme il a pu avoir avec
le CF et que
ce sera l'incarcération
c'est une belle rencontre avec
c'est bon
[Musique]
et de l'affection
sont presque on était trop proche du
coup la relation éducateur
mais je ne place sans cesse
il faut elle était fait la barrière elle
n'existait plus
si on avait pas fait la remarque deux et
après aussi c'est dans les propos que le
jeûne aussi a pu me tenir par moment
il m'a dit c'est dommage que tu sois pas
mon père
là forcément ça
remue quand même
[Musique]
ce soir c'est Max qui assure la
permanence jusqu'à 7h le lendemain Jean
Le Veilleur de Nuit l'accompagne
max relate l'incident du cannabis dans
un cahier pour passer l'info aux
collègues
on se rend pas compte des fois on est
dans la famille c'est
vraiment des déstructuré il y a plus de
place d'enfants d'adultes tout est
confondu donc c'est vrai que nous on a
un idéal
c'est un essai de donner un exemple
voilà faut pas fumer il faut pas boire
il faut se lever le matin travailler
mais en fait ils sont pas du tout dans
les mêmes repères que nous quoi donc des
fois on veut trop être dans notre projet
à nous et en fait le jeune est
complètement décalé quoi on va essayer
de vendre de lui faire de le reprendre
un peu avec lui peut-être lui proposer
une sortie des fois une malade en nature
ça les ça les rebooste parce que faire
de la répression de l'interdiction est
rentrée dedans dans le jeûne ça ça le
fait péter au bout d'un moment ça marche
pas non plus donc
bonne nuit
un jeune qui désobéit ça cache souvent
un mal-être sur lequel il doit
travailler avec l'aide de ses éducateurs
[Musique]
c'est toute la subtilité du travail de
Max entre fermeté et bienveillance
des fois l'été on part avec deux jeunes
à la plage c'est une activité éducative
mais bon c'est quand même cool il y a
des moments on se dit on a un super
travail quoi c'est génial et le soir
même boum il incident on se prend la
tête en rentrant à la maison mais il y a
des bons moments heureusement sinon moi
j'aurais arrêté déjà tu aimes ton métier
[Musique]
ça c'est quand même des premiers
endroits où je vais où j'entends à ce
point dire j'aime mon métier
on essaie de se persuader
maintenant on a commencé à peu près en
même temps donc ça fait quasiment ça
fera 4 ans cet été donc oui quatre ans
entre guillemets supporter des jeunes
comme ça le moyen c'est de si on n'était
pas ça
c'est le temps moyen passé par un
éducateur dans un centre éducatif fermé
beaucoup ont des parcours atypiques Max
a d'abord été barman puis prof de sport
avant de trouver sa voie et de faire une
formation de trois ans
ce soir là je comprends en écoutant max
Guillaume et les autres que leur job
bouffe leur vie ce qu'il donne aux
gamins n'est pas quantifiable une
présence un appui un ressort du désir
pour tenter de mieux repartir dans leur
vie
[Musique]
le lendemain c'est le grand jour pour JB
il souffle ses 18 bougies
et tu te rends compte que si tu poursuis
tes délits n'espère pas que la loi va
vraiment changer
les réponses sont pas du tout du même
et c'est le grand départ JB efface son
nom du tableau des ados placés et ouvre
une nouvelle page de sa vie
il a décroché un stage en maçonnerie
qui débouchera peut-être sur un
apprentissage
CEF Narbonne bonjour oui
et on fait la commission oui
ici les places ne restent pas longtemps
en vacances
je finis
[Musique]
JB party un petit nouveau va prendre sa
place
ça risque un peu la neige ça fait des
spaghetti
à la limite
les grands établissements prennent les
réservations à l'avance
aujourd'hui il va arriver
j'accompagne Ahmed pour son entretien
hebdomadaire avec le chef de service
bon ça a pas été non plus une semaine
parfaite il y a il y a quand même eu des
petites incivilités il y a eu des
insultes il y a eu de la provocation
d'éducateur à toucher la tête des
éducateurs est-ce qu'on te touche
Ahmed ne touchera pas un centime des 10
euros d'argent de poche que donne chaque
semaine le ministère de la Justice à
chaque mineur tu le sais qu'on vous
empêche pas être en colère mais en tout
cas de pas franchir la ligne parce que
bon il y a quatre insultes si tu veux si
on applique la loi stricto sensus
on est déjà dans le rouge là
et le fait d'insulter un éducateur en
CEF c'est une circonstance à gravante
donc ce type de réponse quand quelque
chose qui te plaît pas à mon avis tu es
capable de faire
l'entretien quand on était en train de
parler là il t'a formulé un avis avec
lequel tu n'étais pas d'accord
de te répondre ça il t'a pas insulté on
te répondant ça à ce qu'il y a c'est que
ça t'a pas plu il me faisait ça fait
deux trois fois dans la séance
on dirait me chercher
je m'étais soit comme vous avez dit je
continue mes émotions mieux qu'avant je
suis relevé
en arrivant avant moi avant maintenant
j'essaie de me contrôler pour ça donc
c'est parfait avant tu l'auras agressé
on tombe dans l'insulte
donc maintenant la prochaine étape je
vais te demander d'être arrogant donc ça
veut dire à une réponse est-ce que ce
bidon tu lui réponds ben non c'est toi
qui est bidon par exemple là on est plus
dans les sculpteur c'est pas acceptable
mais c'est une amélioration et après
l'objectif c'est d'être dans le verre
ils ont écouté je ne suis pas du tout
d'accord je lui dis vous avez une
réponse de quand alors bon là on est
c'est pas tout à fait une insulte quand
je pense pas que c'est puni par la loi
par contre on a au niveau de
l'incorrection donc est-ce qu'on peut
pas trouver une autre réponse que vous
avez une réponse de con c'est clair vous
êtes capable de former les choses
correctement
inventif pour trouver la répartie
ces jeunes qui ont en général une vie
personnelle en vrac passe en moyenne 8
mois ici huit mois pour sortir de la
délinquance c'est peu c'est dur ça ne
marche pas toujours je suis bluffé par
le travail de l'équipe et par la foi du
directeur on représente le monde des
adultes sur lequel il y a une
problématique pour eux de repère déjà
avec ce monde des adultes de vouloir
s'en écarter sur un esprit de haine sur
un esprit de vengeance on ne sait pas ça
va dépendre de son parcours de vie on se
doit d'être neutre on se doit d'être
juste le plus possible on n'est pas
parfait on est d'accord mais si on veut
renouer un minimum de sensations et de
sentiments de confiance et de
rapprochement du monde des adultes avec
eux à mon avis il faut développer quand
même certaines choses que la société
véhicule dont l'autorité et sinon on est
plus cohérent les limites les limites
peuvent les rassurer par moments on dit
que tu es raide comme directeur
c'est possible mais je pense être juste
alors effectivement je suis pour aussi
dire la vérité quand il le faut à 17 ans
c'est pas des petits anges non plus qui
sont attachants ils sont à entendre et
écouter à accompagner il faut donner du
coeur ça c'est clair tueur professionnel
j'entends
et à la fois quand il faut dire STOP
faut dire STOP pourquoi pas trop
d'affects il en faut mais
ça peut t'emmener
et si ça t'emmène trop tu peux perdre de
l'objectivité pour donner une réponse à
un moment donné il faudra sanctionner tu
vas dire quand même celui-là je l'aime
bien le petit canard son père il est
alcoolo ou son père le bas sa mère elle
est pas là bon ben c'est pas grave mais
non faute parce que tu vas de faire que
reproduit ce qui a amené le jeune ici
[Musique]
à la nuit tombée le nouveau débat
il s'appelleradu il est roumain et ne
parle pas un mot de français
à peine le temps de faire les
présentations et déjà les questions
habituelles fusent
et là pourquoi braquer
radou sors de garde à vue il est très
perturbé il pleure beaucoup
[Musique]
il est mis au parfum et découvre sa
future chambre
ion
alors ok
[Musique]
qui vient de lui tomber dessus
le lendemain je quitte le centre avec
cette image de Radoux qui est dans la
cour complètement perdu une semaine plus
tard il va s'évader on est sans
nouvelles de lui à ce jour
JB appelle Guillaume chaque semaine mais
il a arrêté son stage en maçonnerie et
cherche un job en intérim
depuis trois nouveaux sont arrivés max
Myriam Guillaume et les autres
continuent sans relâche leur travail
contre le destin donner un cadre du sens
et de l'envie à ses gamins sans repère
mon séjour à Narbonne est terminé demain
ailleurs j'ai rendez-vous avec d'autres
hommes d'autres femmes aux vies peu
ordinaires